welcome back to
this chamber and indeed welcome to this
district planning meeting today
thursday the 30th of september 2021 the
setup for this meeting has been designed
to mitigate for covid therefore in the
interests of member and officer safety
all present should work to the protocols
agreed at council on the 2nd of
september 2021
as this meeting is being streamed live
and recorded for the benefit of the
camera my name is councillor mark hurd
and i'm the chairman of this committee
by being present in this meeting you are
giving consent to being recorded
during each item members please put your
hand up if you wish to speak and i will
invite you at the appropriate time
please note the youtube live stream and
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore
when invited to speak please remember to
turn them on
referencing a page or paragraph number
on the agenda papers and keep your
contributions clear and concise and
please remember to turn off your
microphone when finished
finally i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit
is the door to my left behind this top
table
berna can i have apologies for absence
please thank you chairman we've received
apologies from councillors bell durham
helm jarvis morley none and schemes
thank you
thank you very much
agenda item number three is declarations
of interest members are reminded that
they are required to declare any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests which they know they might
have in items of
business on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive at the
code of conduct for members they are
reminded that they will need to repeat
their declarations at the appropriate
point in the meeting
and leave the room if required under the
code of conduct unforeseen interests
must be declared similarly at the
appropriate time
do we have any members who wish to
declare an interest councillor fleming
thank you chairman and non-pecuniary as
a member of essex county council who are
consultees thank you thank you very much
and councillor stamp
yes the same as councillor fleming i'm a
member of posix county council
non-pecuniary and their council tears
and some of the on the applications
thank you
cancer edwards did i see you around yes
thank you chairman uh my award is the
hayward west award for item number five
thank you thank you councilman morris
yeah i'd like to
i'd like to declare a non-pecuniary
interest um i'm a west sport uh haybirds
westward member and also my daughter
frequents
mcdonald's and will probably kill me if
i do anything to harm them thank you
thank you cancer
casafluka thank you chairman i wasn't
going to declare this but another
members pointed out that i have been
known to frequent mcdonald's restaurant
like i guess a lot of other people i'm
sure we all have uh yeah councillor
boyce
thank you german i officially opened
mcdonald's when it first arrived
excellent
thank you very much
agenda item or then members
minutes of the previous meeting so it's
recommended that the minutes of this
meeting the district planning committee
was held on the 5th of august they're
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true and accurate record they're
presented for accuracy only
i so move do i have a seconder
councillor maze thank you very much
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy please indicate they wish to
speak
are you happy to accept those by ascent
thank you
we move on now to agenda item five
twenty one
zero zero one eight four slash res this
is land at broad street green road and
langford road and maypole road great
tottenham haybridge langford and alting
this has been referred to this committee
as a strategic site within the strategic
submitted local development plan and the
principle of the development has been
accepted as the site forms part of the
north heybridge garden suburb i
understand mr johnson that you're
presenting this
yes
okay i'll hand over to you then in that
case thank you
maggie chairman
this application represents the first
reserved matter submission to the north
haybridge garden suburb
strategic site reference s2d
in relation to the hybrid planning
consent
granted on appeal on the 25th of october
2019
under reference 15 stroke 00419
out
the development granted on appeal on the
reference was
a part outline part detailed hybrid
applications for mixed-use development
at 3.1.2 of the report the full
description is set out
the only thing i'll point out
in terms of the description
is that it being an outline
and part detailed the only detailed
elements related to
the relief road between broad street
green road and langford road
and also the construction of initial gas
and electricity substations all the
other elements are the outline of which
this is
a
the first submission
so i'll just take you through the slides
and sort of speak to the slides and
comment at the same time
so here we have the
location plan we've got the broad
location plan here
the applicant's ownership of land
outlined in blue
and also the application site in red
then we can see the hatch the area in
the middle which specifically relates to
this element of the outline application
as
stated in the description
this element relates to the landscaping
of
um
largely along the relief road
um and those areas you can see
highlighted there
and just to sort of point out
within the hatched areas those sort of
uh
sort of hexagonal
shaped areas do represent
the outline of the residential areas
parcels one and two
obvious
no detailed elements are part of this
application but is to show the
landscaping that will be flanking dopes
so here we have the relief road and the
part of the area
um
in
more detail there
so just turn into the commentary the
first reserved matters application
relates to the strategic landscaping
elements within the first phase of the
development
subsequent landscaping
reserve matters
on the rest of the site will be
submitted in respect of future phases
and for clarification this is the first
of five phases
the submission covers the strategic
landscaping roads paths open spaces and
earthworks
the application does not include as i
mentioned just now any part of the
actual relief route
as that layout
was approved under the detailed
application
however it does include the landscaping
as i said earlier along the size of
phase one of the relief road
consent
1500412 the hybrid application
also approved a number of parameter
plans which are relevant to this reserve
matter submission
which includes the land use parameter
plan the green and blue infrastructure
parameter plan and the access and
movement parameter plan
and the outline consent requires that
these reserve matters are carried out in
accordance with those plans
and just to sort of point out
the report makes reference for a number
of other applications which have been
submitted under
conditional discharge
throughout which are relevant to certain
of the elements within this application
which we have here
so 3.1.4 condition 11
of the outline application required that
before or concurrent with the first
reserved matters application for this
site which is this application
a strategic phasing plan for the site
was to be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
a strategic phasing plan was submitted
and agreed
under reference 2005039
which is a discharge of condition
application
this application covers a strategic
landscaping for the phase one area of
the development
a subsequent submission will cover the
residential parcels within the phase one
area
so that phasing plan
denotes how these applications will come
through
um and the phasing plan has been agreed
that this would be the first phase
and the first wave will cover the
various elements so this is relent the
landscaping the residential
uh
for phase one will also be submitted but
it will be related to that phase
and i'm just drawing this
clarity for members so you can be aware
that this is
the phases will relate to the various
parts of the development as they come
through for the phasing of the skin
so again
just in more detail here
and just to point out you can see the
sort of um
well elliptical type shapes
um within
some of these areas the hatch there is
the dr001
uh
dr003
um
those elliptical areas relate to
the attenuation basins
that form part
of the sustainable urban drainage scheme
um as is within the report so again just
while that plan is up just to draw that
to your your attention
so the key elements of the strategic
landscaping covered in this submission
are
landscaping along the western section
of the relief road
so
this is the area we're talking along
here
design of the open space at the entrance
of the site
from the relief roads through maple road
so this is this area here this will be
the main entrance into the site
the design of the main spine road which
runs through the main section of the
site
covered by phase one
which is our spine road running through
here
the design of green corridors that form
the eastern boundaries of residential
parcels one and two
which are also included within phase one
as i said before the residential parcels
and their development is not part of
this application
apologies
so
these are the green corridors these are
this is parcel one residential parcel
one and two
these are
the green corridors which run along
the eastern edge
the design of the central open space
within phase one containing a formal
garden
and play area that leap
which is a locally equipped area of play
which is located opposite the future
site
of the school approved under the outline
application
so this is this area here
the leap is within here
there are a number of orchards again
within this site
and the area of the future school will
be in this area here
the design of the acoustic bond
that lies to the south of the relief
road and the north of the residential
parcel one within phase one
so the bond is within this area here
3.1.7
sets out condition 31.
um any reserved matters application made
pursuant to this approval that seeks the
approval of landscaping details
shall include a detailed landscaping
scheme
this reserve matters application is
fundamentally tied in with the
directions under those
conditions
hence the compartmental
of these applications for us to consider
the particular elements of it
this application has been supported by a
detailed landscaping scheme and
landscaping statement which accords with
the requirements of condition 31.
this submission also includes details to
comply
with condition 28
which is a network of pedestrian and
cycle routes
along
those main arteries
that we see in that plan there
the submission also includes details to
comply with condition 28 and condition
18 the arborio cultural report
it must be noted that condition 31
landscaping details is split into two
parts
and the two parts of condition
31
was agreed to be split into two part
under a non-material
planning application which was submitted
earlier on this year
so
in reading condition 31 it is now there
are now two parts of a a b this relates
to
the a section of condition 31.
so again just drilling down in a bit
more detail here
and as pointed out
these are the
green corridors running down
there's also open space along here
to the south
of this open space as the bellway site
which we're familiar with
and again just pointing out these
attenuation
basins as part of
the sustainable urban drainage system
so in conclusion
and then i'll just run through the
remainder of the slides
the principle of the development of the
site has been accepted
as the site forms part of the north
heybridge garden suburb strategic site
s2d
the strategic landscaping shown for
phase one of the development is
considered to accord with the north
hebrew strategic master plan framework
the north heybridge strategic design
code
and the outline planning permission to
which it relates
it is considered that this first phase
of strategic landscaping sets out a
well-designed framework of green spaces
and linkages that will ensure the
development as a whole delivers
the high quality vibrant and distinctive
neighborhoods that the site aims to
achieve
so again just
moving through the remainder of plans
you can see the
leap area the gardens as i mentioned
earlier
a general
layout arrangement
you can always come back to any of these
slides if members do wish
again just a cross section
of some of the attenuation basins
known as pond one
in that slide
these are the other basins that ran
along the eastern section
of the residential parcels and cross
sections
uh showing the slope in size and the
the depth
um
as this is the landscaping proposals the
the sustainable urban drainage system is
incorporated into the landscaping
proposals
um
obviously the use of these
basins will depend on
the ambient weather conditions as they
may be
throughout the duration of this
development
again just a few more details here
there
glitch widening goes just going into
some of the details i'll just
skip through this fairly quickly this is
the noise bond
section
um the noise band section um as
mentioned earlier
um provides the acoustic provides the
acoustic barrier
to the residential
um that will be delivered under parcel
one
that's the leap it's more detailed
and here we do some
surfacing curbing arrangements
i can always come back to this
this is a useful slide showing the cross
section showing the bond
there the relief road
um
the uh
we can see the the ditch that's the
swale there then the bond
uh footpath
um
note in the segregate safe segregation
and uh a residential
frontage there
and the lower plan just serves the cross
section
um in plan form
but these are just some refuge tracking
area these are mentioned in the report
um
but again just to show that the
landscaping will work
with
highway movement of vehicles
satisfactorily
and these are just contour plans and
again just to remind members this is a
sloping site
there is north to south there is about a
four and a half
meter grade fall
um
this is just bringing that into
attention
so on that note i will just go back to
the original layout planned
and
i'll end my presentation there chairman
thank you
thank you very much indeed
so we have um two speakers uh one is the
agent mr kevin coleman
and i invite you mr coleman to come
forward
mr sesame first is a beggar pardon
we have uh an objector then in that case
um
mr david sismi it's nice to see you
again mr susmi back in the chamber
so as i'm sure
as i'm sure you know and you have two
minutes
thank you chairman and members thank you
for your time um i objected to this
application because into alia it sought
to drop a screening hedge from the
western end of the new road which had
been a feature of the original
permission
this had been a tiny commitment from the
developer in its original application
unwilling as they were to incorporate a
noise fund next to the relief road
except next to their proposed houses
and so had i not noticed this deletion
in the plans for the application this
would have gone the same way as the
developer's earlier commitment of
applied alleviation scheme
on which basis arguably the whole
location
was first identified as a strategic site
so i welcome the screening hedge has now
been added back in
but it shows that it continues to be a
huge commitment simply to keep the
developer even to their smaller promises
and now before concrete has even poured
um all the conditions of the original
commission have been approved
the developer is presiding over which
contractors closing parts of maypole
road for days at a time without highway
permits in place and cutting down trees
and hedgerows seemingly protected by the
conditions of the original application
i'm a big supporter of development in
the right locations with the right
infrastructure and built being
considerate and the build-out being
considerate to neighbors
i recognize that given the original
appeal success this application today is
likely to succeed but i say this
this will soon be a huge development in
modern and it's vital that the council
ensures that the developer
delivers on the commitments it's made
and manages the construction and build
out appropriately that's likely to
require
much more effort from the enforcement
planning and environmental health teams
than i'm afraid it's been evident so far
thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed mr susmi
um i now call upon the agent mr kevin
coleman
and to come forward
thank you thank you mr coleman you have
two minutes um only for uh speaking in
line with the scheme thank you thank you
very much and thank you for the
opportunity to speak tonight
um as members will be aware and has been
touched on already the north heybridge
garden suburb is a key part of the local
plan and a key part of the council's
land
supply the principles of the development
are well established as the
presentations touched on both through
your local plan policies and of course
through the outline planning permission
itself
we're now working with your officers on
discharging the relevant details to
allow us to get to the point where we
can commence the strategic
infrastructure on site and start
developing the open space
all as has been pointed out in
accordance with the approved phasing
plan
application before the committee tonight
seeks approval for reserve matters for
landscaping infrastructure only the key
elements being the landscaped open space
that will form an attractive entrance
feature from maple road the extensive
new tree and hedge planting along the
approved relief road
the tree-lined spine road that leads
through to the local centre and the new
school
the network of accessible footpaths and
the extensive areas of open space
including the play area by the local
centre
the purpose of this application is to
now enable us to make a start on the key
pieces of infrastructure and allow the
main landscaping and open spaces to
become established
and members will note from the update
report that the details of the drainage
for this part of the site have been
approved
and it's our intention to deliver these
early in the scheme
i would like to thank the parish council
for highlighting the need to include the
hedge on the south side of the relief
road as it's been mentioned
back in july we amended the plans
accordingly to include the hedgerow
referred to there's some
3746 feet of native hedge planting along
the relief road
so from our point of view the scheme is
a quality scheme it's entirely in
accordance with the parameter plans it's
entirely in accordance with your design
code and that's why we're respectively
asking for approval tonight thank you
thank you very much indeed mr coleman so
members i'll open this up to debate and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments you have on the report
councillor edwards
thank you chairman i actually have a
number of questions if i may
um
firstly
in june this year
there was an application for a
non-material amendment
21 stroke 005 v8
which was a changing word in condition
number nine
and if i may have read part of this out
and it states no development with any
part of the site or on any phase of the
development
shall take place until a detailed
surface water drainage scheme for that
part of the site
or phase
based on sustainable drainage principles
has been submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
now my question is first of all
is this class as a as a part of the
development which has actually been
without a drainage scheme that's been
produced
council i haven't seen
a scheme for drainage
can i ask that question first please
are you over here with that mr johnson
right um
thank you chairman
at um 5.5.2
of the report
which state and i'll quickly just run
through that um
paragraph there
the submission relates to the phase one
strategic landscaping and provides
details of the size
location and gradients of the surface
water attenuation basins
and drainage network with within this
phase of the within this phase of the
development
the submission follows the parameter
plans set out outline stage
as well as the overall agreed drainage
strategy
the technical details of the surface
water drainage scheme
are dealt with through the condition
nine of the original hybrid consent
and there is a current submission in
relation to this condition
at 21
0 5
1 2
det which is a discharge so there's a
con
there's a current application
which is currently before officers which
is
undetermined
detailing the
the the flood level uh the
yeah details of the surface water
drainage scheme all right well that's
that's coming
okay and then just to just to just give
our context to that um at 5.5.3
the agrees drainage strategy is that due
to the relatively shallow groundwater
uh infiltration drainage techniques will
not be utilized on the site however
other suds
techniques will be used
which will allow
the suds train
um submitted as part of the fra
to
1500419 so there is a link back to the
outline application the hybrid
application which which was
approved in
2019
so the thing is to get the comprehensive
appreciation it's looking at the several
documents concurrently there is the
outline scheme there is the
um the flood risk assessment within that
scheme
there is the um discharge of conditions
on the current line which are coming
forward
this application is not the
detailed application regarding the flood
alleviation scheme this is how it sits
within the landscape
context
thank you
can i just say though that there is an
error there is a member's update on this
there is an error at the end of
paragraph 5.5.2
and the final sentence says there is a
current submission under condition 9 for
drainage and this is for phase 2
drainage
so the drainage that goes with this is a
reserved matters
which has already been approved under
another application
but the wording of the amendment of the
work of
of number nine
states that no development should take
place until
the
drainage has been approved by the local
authority
yeah just to clarify well well that's
the key word there no development shall
take place um it doesn't mean part of it
is this class as development no this is
the application
okay
if you understand what i mean is the
submission of the application the
if members um approve this um
um
this again will be tied in with um
details of any other application in
terms of when development can commence
jim can i come back
um
the landscaping
i was going to ask about the spine road
but you've clarified what that is though
the landscaping for the
relief road
includes as we've just mentioned
attenuation basins
which is part of the flood alleviation
or the suns
includes as you mentioned
attenuation basis
which is part of the science which we
haven't got before us
right the
well what's flanking the relief roads um
is the landscaping proposal which
includes
the swales
okay so those are the ditches that will
run alongside which is in the culverts
the dishes well the ditches and the
colors as part of this landscaping
scheme
the trees being cut down
how is the management of those trees
being replanted going to be
looked at
or some of them because some of them
have to stay down because obviously the
road's going to be built but there are
trees going to in some of the conditions
trees
are to be replanted along
the relief road and along maple road
or is that part of another application
to come in
our reserve matters
right thank you councillor um
as i said there are there are a number
of documents that form a suite of how
this application is going to be coming
forward
um some have been approved already some
are being part of the the the hybrid
application
which was allowed on appeal um some will
be subject to discharge of conditions
now in relation to the trees
um
which you mentioned and i am fully aware
of
these um
were and and if i just take from
this information this clarification
which i got from the developer regarding
this
um
and if i can just read it to give you
that context
as part of the hybrid planning
commission the arboricultural impact
assessment
submitted and agreed
identified a number of trees and hedges
to be removed as to facilitate the
construction of the relief group
some limited arboricultural works have
recently been undertaken
a long broad street green road in line
with the approved our borough cultural
impact assessment
that was in 2015. yes
741 yeah
these works fall within the hatched area
and are permitted
by
condition 18.
in light of this
um
and this is
well
this was obviously the issue we were
considering as to whether there was a
breach of planning control yes and
having looked at that looked at the
details
corresponded that with the patched area
to so far there is no breach of planning
control that has been identified
yes thank you but i was just concerned
about replanting
how is that going to be managed
are we going to manage or see how that
there
is yeah that will be part of the overall
landscaping
just to just to just to continue that
um
and then again just to give some because
i
imagine this matter would have come up
um notwithstanding this the trees and
hedges were inspected for nesting birds
and the presence of suitable
uh roosting features for bats so that
was also covered as part of the part
part of that that that consideration
the biocultural impact assessment
submitted and agreed detailed the
removal as i said of these trees
uh along the section of mayport road
um and this includes a section of
hedging we did we touched on the hedging
earlier and
the new hedging that will be planted
along there so as part of the overall
landscaping skin there will be a
comprehensive um
well tree planting and tree replacement
scheme
okay thank you and if
i have further questions jim if i may
yes please um
i'm glad to see that hebrews paris
council
when they put in their response
for hedgerows that that's been has been
taken into consideration and you are
planting
was it three thousand something foot
of hedgerows along the relief road is
that bad north and south mr coleman
um in feet
i had it in one and a half
is that north and south north of lake
river and south both sides
right
thank you
um just on that i think i think that
there are details of uh planting on
pages 20
and uh 21 i think
i i've been reading this for two days
and then from
can i
um sorry i'll break i'll give way to
anyone okay um councillor white
um thank you mr chairman i've actually
got four questions but shall i give you
all the questions at once and then wait
for the answers or do you want the one
at a time
right okay the first one is under 5.6
the um there doesn't appear to be a
natural england biodiversity matrix
version 3 which natural england
recommend for all planning applications
and indeed i've got pretty good
experience of them
um because trees and grass and general
greenery are not biodiversity increases
you have to have certain things and it's
worked out on a formal matrix
um to get the biodiversity impacts it
also gives you what the harm is and then
you should increase it by at least 10
percent on a large application to
actually cover the biodiversity harm
so um
that is the first one
all right thank you councillor um
the only point i can draw on that is
that
i set out in the report
um
[Music]
natural england have stated that
contingent upon the application aligning
with the recreational disturbance
mitigation packaged
outlined in the hra
dated
15th of the 8th 2019
they have no objections to this reserve
matters application yes but well i
understand that that's the rams group
and that's a totally separate thing the
biodiversity matrix is something that
applicants should do and authorities
should be aware of because it's an
absolute clinical diagnosis of the state
of the ground now the harm that
development does and how you are going
to
mitigate the harm and i would have
thought or would have hoped that the
authority i've mentioned this with every
large application in the district
and i asked the authority to take on
board that we actually start
and getting these reports done and
actually evaluate them because otherwise
it's just the applicant's um
consultant saying oh we'll add some
grass here and some water there but that
isn't how the biodiversity matrix works
you know some things have a high
biodiversity gain and others don't so
how do we know what the harm is and how
do we know what the gain is unless we
have this biodiversity matrix so that's
the first thing i would say i think they
should be deferred until we get this
because for me there's not enough
information regarding the biodiversity
harm and mitigation so that's that's the
first question but i understand that
we've not done one well just just just
come back on that i mean if we look at
the the the commentary from play
services ecology and this is specific to
this type of application
um
they were consulted specifically on
these matters
um and would comment accordingly as to
what is appropriate
um it might come out it's just that they
haven't got a technical tool for
actually diagnosing it just saying well
there's a field there surely with a big
development as sensitive as this we
should absolutely be doing our best
and it's part of our policies to
actually improve and enhance the natural
biodiversity of our very important
district and improve improve the green
infrastructure we get it at every
meeting that we go to all right
about that
again just to reiterate and as i've said
with uh
some answers before
this is a reserve matters application
it's on the back of an outline
application
there was a very detailed hra submission
as part of that outline application
these are the details which are stemming
from it which they're flying from
the the matter you're relating to is if
this was if the application had come to
us in the first instance these are the
these are the broad parameters that we
would be seeking to secure in those
applications this is a reserved matters
application string down to the details
once those broad parameters have been
considered
hence that's why that's not addressed on
this application
the broad context of that has been
agreed under the outline
or hybrid application
um and hence the response of the
statutory consorties uh which we have in
this report
um there is no requirement for that
under these reports because of the
nature of these reports but also how
they fit in with the overall outline
scheme
i thought this was this was a formal
requirement by um the the government to
actually put these in and it started off
with matrix one matrix two and matrix 3
is the new one and i understand it's
going to be compulsory to have a 10
habitat gain and i understood that
natural england advised that the way to
get a a secure gain or an accurate gain
was to use the matrix or does mulden not
i can't really say much more about this
counselor but just to repeat what i've
just said this is a reserve matters on
on the back of a of a of a hybrid
application where the the broad
principles of the whole development has
been considered thank you okay right
okay well i've got my next question um
just before you do that council well i
just got um just looking up here this
biodiversity um
metric was only published on the 7th of
july the new one but you had version 2
before version 3 and then version 1.
version 3 is the latest one so it could
have been two or one
okay thank you what's your next question
uh the next question is um i've got my
phone
um under
5.7.2 um the parking i'm concerned about
the routes in and out for the rescue
trucks and fire and rescue because they
look very narrow to me
um are they going to have double your
lines on them and are people going to be
allowed to park on because obviously
that becomes an issue in these modern
estates where they're very narrow roads
i'm an htv driver and so that's the
concern because i know you sometimes in
big lorries or big trucks you can get
even but you can't always get out
particularly if they're rigid i know the
refuse trucks are very small butty
lorries they don't have the long
wheelbase
um but that's still an issue and while
i'm on the in roads infrastructure um
what i don't seem to have is anything
you mentioned conditioned condition 28
with the footpaths and cycle routes but
as another molden district council
policy we had in every single new
application this has been policy for a
long time but we would have bridleways
along with footpaths and cycle paths and
yet again unless i'm wrong i can't see
any mention of broadway so the two um
road related
issues
i'm not sure the yellow lines would
relate to this application
i don't think so this is just for
landscaping and uh this is for
landscaping the phase one of the
entrance screen the spine road the green
corridors
yeah yeah and the acoustic band that's
what that's what that comes under spine
roads because these spine roads what
when i read the report it's what the
fire and the refuse vehicles have to use
and they look narrow to me so i'm i'm
not very good on wits but we've got
other htv drivers are probably better
than i am
um what happens in these modern estates
is you get people parking on them and
you can't get these lorries through they
block all the spine roads up so are they
going to have parking are they going to
have prohibited parking i mean these are
important for the spine roads the little
residential ones not so much i'll have
to stop you there council right because
this is not about yellow lights okay um
so and the last thing then is on i've
also have concerns of the flood levation
not the scheme itself not the buns
my concern is every single time we have
an outline application and we do reserve
matters they say we can't sort out the
fundal evasion now in the funding we've
got to approve the permission first then
we sort out the flood alleviation and
the funding afterwards
every single time we approve the
application and between the developers
and the environment agency it's unviable
we can't do it bad luck mold and you're
not going to get it so
my other concern is can we um defer this
until we get the agreement not
necessarily refuse it but certainly
defer it until we have a concrete scheme
in place and who's going to fund it
whether it's the environment agency you
know i don't mind who funds it but i
just think we need it first otherwise we
approve them and everybody goes oh sorry
you approved it bad luck
so let's try and do it the way around
and be a bit proactive and get the
cart or the horse first not the cart
sorry
i think again we just have to
re-emphasize that this is um
this is for landscaping proposals it
includes the details of where the
attenuation basins
will be and how they will be dealt with
but this application is not the detailed
subs
application
there's been no objection from the
environment agency there's been no
objection from essex county council
highways
and the essex county council suds local
flood authority have also reviewed this
these are all on page 33
and again they don't object to the
granting of
the planning permission for phase one
okay councillor hull
thank you very much i'm just coming back
um
there's plenty of footpaths and and
cycleways which is great um but once
again why is there no bridleways in the
plans
essex has got one of the largest
populations of horses and horse riders
um the roads are getting really busy and
it was my belief that all new
applications should have a bridal way
included in them
thank you
i think again i i have to go back to the
fact that this is a reserved matters
application
this is
submitted on the back of the outline
application
as mentioned earlier there were a number
of parameter plans
which the reserve matters applications
has to comply with
there was no requirement under the
original submission
or bridal ways
in
to be delivered under phase one
at this moment i can't speak about the
other phases but under this application
because this relates specifically to the
landscaping and other elements of of of
movement
as set out in the report there is no
there is no reference to bridal waves
because there is no submission for
bridal ways as part of this and
no
requirement as such under this
application for us to
for example consider a refusal of this
application because there is not a bribe
away
so it's not incumbent upon us under this
application
to have regard or to introduce that
matter a consideration with this
application as much as i do appreciate
what you're saying thank you chairman
would you it does just say also on page
uh page nine i believe
uh no sorry sorry there's another i
forget circle
counselor channel
thank you chairman
um i appreciate this is reserve mata's
application
we had the outline
but uh the lead local flood authority
did make it clear
regarding
the
application that it needed to comply
with the conditions that were applied to
the outline approval
and the officer says noted and discussed
those conditions shall remain well i'm
sorry chairman but i mean the conditions
here have an awful lot
of detail of um according to the
following approved plans and documents
and i don't know if anyone else has had
the time to read through all these
i'm not a professional to understand
every element of this can the officer
thereby give us total assurances that
this reserved matters application does
comply
with all the details and conditions and
requirements of the outline i ask this
because i have been in a committee
previously at a
area level
whereby an officer picked up a slight
difference between what was before the
authority
in the reserve matters to that within
the outline so i want complete
assurances from officers
that this reserve matters application is
totally compliant with the outline that
was approved
also i'd like to know out of interest
have any works commenced on the site
have any trees or any elements been
dabbled with cut down that perhaps
shouldn't have been
ahead of these works or are to do with
other matters surrounding any
development on this proposal
and i would like assurances i think um
chairman also i notice under the
informatives there's about a commuted
some required possibly
and i'm very very surprised to see that
within
the informative number four regarding
trees and non-standard materials
equipment within the existing extent of
the public highway they require
contribution commuted some to cover the
cost of future maintenance for a period
of 15 years
is that the sort of thing that
ordinarily would be enough for in an
informative
surely that should have been picked up
at some stage i'm not sure what stage
weather this stage but i'm a bit shocked
to find elements of a commuted some
being referred to in informative only
um you know i think that's part of the
concern of members that all monies
through any um approvals we give
are clearly defined in any approval to
ensure those commuted sums do come
forward chairman so i'm just very
concerned and are these conditions
sufficient really to cover all the
elements of this application before us
and i say chairman i was not through
laziness with all due respect i have not
had time to read every detail contained
within all these documents i'm not sure
if other members have but also not
having the professional brain
um i just need all those assurances from
the officer please jim
and about any works happening on site
and any trees removed hedgerows removed
or anything like that thank you thank
you
thank you chairman um
no works that would constitute the
commencement of development has taken
place on the site
so i will say that say that
categorically
what works have taken place on the site
are works which are to facilitate
the investigation to then inform
submissions to discharge conditions
so in relation to that um i will speak
to the archaeological
work which has taken place on the site
um
there can be confusion as to
what does commence development but what
was the implicit
within the conditions on the outlying
permission is that
and
if we're looking at for example the
written scheme
of investigation
regarding these matters which provide
the context for which one will carry out
the investigative works to inform the
conditions these were required to be
done before
the details can be submitted
um
again
with my enforcement i'm fully aware of
the issues around that for example and
how that has related
works currently taking place on site
again similarly
in terms of the trees
the response is as
stated to councillor edwards
regarding those matters on the trees
those are not a commencement of the
works
those are trees which have been agreed
um
under plans approved previously to be
removed to facilitate
the development as and when that element
of the development comes forward
um
the the other matter you raised uh
counselor china was regarding the
informative and then the key thing on in
of the informatives
is that it says any trees and
non-standard materials equipment
proposed within
the existing extent of the public
highway
so that's that's the key element there
um and in terms of the commuted sum this
is not the commuted summit in which we
would normally agree as part of
um the development proposal um
but this is something would be solely
they'd have to
um
manage with the highways authority
as opposed to through this application
and the district planning authority
thank you jim okay
you may yeah yes
is this a question counselor because
yeah
could we could we get to it
at the start of my question i'm i said i
don't know that the officer had answered
my question perhaps i hadn't heard in
the right context can the officer assure
me
that this reserved application complies
totally with that of the outline
um all the conditions bearing in mind
what the uh lead flood authority have
said regarding a condition bearing in
mind the monumental list of documents
here that probably members were expected
to read through to understand it and
i've attempted to but they're very very
detailed chairman and i'm not a
professional in all this so that is why
i started off my first question
with that and i'm not sure i heard the
answer i want those assurances chairman
and i have asked now about the hedgerows
act
hope that makes it clear thank you all
right thank you chairman um because i i
i do believe i was answering uh several
questions
um but i can give the
counselor the assurances
that this reserve matters will comply
with those conditions that is the
substance of us assessing these
applications
this is a strategic application has been
subject to
even as part of the reserve matters
pre-applications
there have been um planning performance
agreements discussing these in extreme
details
over the last
18 months at least um
we have comprehensively uh compared
the conditions
on the outline scheme hence the corpus
cross references that you can see within
the report which i do understand and
that was one of the reasons why
i set out initially that there are also
a suite of accompanying
applications discharge of conditions
non-material applications which all form
part of this context and i do appreciate
it does seem like a bit of a jigsaw
but we have comprehensively gone through
this
um
for want a better terminology picked up
the developer where we felt it was
necessary sought clarification sought
the relevant amendments and we've also
saw the relevant assurances um written
into their submissions so we are quite
we are confident and that's why this
report is in front of you that
um those assurances um can be satisfied
thank you chairman all right thank you
councillor
yeah thank you chairman um
this may fall into the the remit of this
conversation but it is to do with the uh
acoustic band and the fence that's shown
on slide 19 of the slide pack
um
with the relief road and the swale
um it gives a a drawing it's 15 meters
wide and obviously with a deflective
fence at the top and large mature
growing trees in there um
it's it's it's a divine place to live
because there's the smallest car
illustrated shown here um so it'd be a
very quiet road i'd expect but has the
engineering information considered the
volume of traffic
at its peak when the whole thing's built
out
the different uh acoustic variations
that will come from the time when the
band is actually uh established to when
the housings are built in to the trees
that will probably be growing up so i.e
would it be really really noisy at first
and then take many years to grow
because
the volume of houses that we're putting
in this monster um that build is is is
vast so i want to know has that
engineering report is in these documents
because i can't find it um and like
council channel i'm no expert and i
haven't read every single detail but i'm
interested in that on the noise effect
of the people who will be living uh
actually close to the road
and the effect of the earth bund so
that's the first point
and the second point is to do with um
the the leap and the orchard
i noticed that there's a generous 14
trees seven on either side of the
orchard uh is there any chance that that
could actually be made into a as more of
a significant number of trees rather
than just seven on either side or is
that drawing
locked in
you know hook line and sinker
because they better like sharing if if
they're apple trees
thank you
um
[Music]
thanks chairman um but just in here with
your second question um
the
um
the drawing that we have um i i assume
you you got the number 14 by counting
them is that correct
i managed to use all my fingers thank
you
um
sorry just give me a
a second there um
so this one
yeah um
thank you chairman for just drawing that
out um i mean 5.2.11 speaks about the
the
green and blue infrastructure parameter
plants
um
and that the
submission
conforms with this parameter plan
with the location and extent of open
space adhering talks about the leap
um but i would also just sort of
cross-reference that in terms of um
[Music]
the arboricultural
assessment under 5.7.3
um
where the
council's three consultants has been
consulted in terms of that
um
he has agreed that that is satisfactory
um i can't say that the number 14
um
in terms of a density
was stated specifically has been
satisfactory or unsatisfactory but by
his support of the scheme
um
it is considered to be acceptable
so that's that's my response to that now
in terms of the of the earth bond
can i just pause you there did you want
to come back on that point yes i'd say
thank you chairman appreciate very short
members um so so
again because it's always a learning
curve for me so with these plans if i
look and see what's here this is what
will be here because it's deemed as
acceptable so there's no variation to be
able to say that they would look at that
and potentially increase the density to
a decent amount of different type of
planting
is that correct
what's here is here and this is cast in
stone because people think that's fine
well on the face of it that is correct
yes thank you mr johnson
uh just in terms of the earth bond um
the application was supported by um
a
acoustic assessment specific
to the earth bond
um
the
appropriate modeling for that that type
of structure
with that road with this relationship
too and the interface with residential
had been carried out as part of that
assessment
um
and
the earth bond i know when you pose your
question initially it was sort of a
timeline maturity volume of traffic over
x period i do appreciate that
um these um these assessments are
normally based on a worst case scenario
um given the expected volume of traffic
over a given period with this scale of
development
that had been that takes place that's
part of the
sort of basic inputs into these modeling
packages
again what i would also say and as
mentioned with uh
on other comments earlier
there's a whole package of measures when
it comes to these
to this type of scheme an outline with a
reserve matters and
what will accompany this but not part of
this application
um is when the residential developments
come forward
and that the residential developments
themselves will have to conform with a
form of
detail and material that is appropriate
for that relationship with that road
and
while i can't put my
hand on the line immediately that is
stated within the report
as well um
as a sort of a heads up
in terms of how the whole acoustic
environment
of the road and the develop and the
housing development
will be developed coming forward thank
you chairman
thank you thank you um
and you had a question about the bund
councillor lagan did you
yeah just as just to follow just because
it does mention uh chair that says no
for additional information the acoustic
abundant offense please refer to the
engineering drawings but i'd like to see
those drawings to look at the plan as
what mr johnson just said with the the
progressive nature of the materials etc
that could be used because that model it
would have to be done
as you quite rightly said mr johnson
the details about the materials that
that's not part of the plants because
the materials relate to the residential
development which will come forward in
in future in future phases
um
but i mean we've got that we've got the
section there i believe there is a
um another more detailed plan but i'd
have to scan through it to find
exactly where it is
um
which i think there's so some fencing
elements um
and i do apologize i could be going the
wrong way
so that's the timber bridge details
find it i wouldn't be able to put my
hand on it right now
um unless members
want me to go through that
through the chair i think to probably
not necessarily to go through and dig
down but i think it's an important
informant informative document um to
look at because noise especially with
the environment that we're talking about
the volume of housing and the potential
volume of traffic up there
the noise is is harmful
so i'd like to make sure that this is
mitigated to to the maximum effect
thank you but you know as i said i mean
there is allusions to that with it
within the report um if i come across
here i will through the chair just bring
that back to your attention thank you
thank you council fluker is next thank
you chairman i'm grateful um question mr
johnson just clarity really regarding
the local development plan and strategic
sites is it a requirement of strategic
sites to provide for brighter ways i've
got two further questions dependent on
the answer to that
i think not in this application
um
thank you sherman i mean there isn't a
sort of blanche requirement for the
provision of vital waste could you turn
your microphone off please yeah
there isn't a car blanche requirement
for the provision of bridal ways um
those are matters that would um in
consider well in using the local plan
we'd consider in terms of its local
requirements here they may be specific
or
appropriate as part of local character
local amenities in some areas but there
isn't that specific requirement
that if a bridal way is not provided
an application could be potentially
refused
yeah chairman would you like to come
back on that because um we often tie
ourselves up without like planning
permission and what concerns me about
this if i can
take members attention to paragraph
3.1.3
and it says quite clearly that we we are
going to uh
consider future landscaping we do have
matters applications and i get that
i think the next paragraph means that
where it says the submission i think it
means this submission covers the
strategic landscaping i think i've got
that right
and if that is the case what can happen
is we could
approve this outline application for all
of the strategic matters and then when
it comes to something like a bride way
the applicant could say well you haven't
considered this within the strategic
application which covers landscaping
roads paths and open spaces and
earthworks and that follows that it
could be that there is
no way to include by the ways if we
agree that now that's the way i look at
this
so um i think that um
you know
we don't want to tie ourselves over this
and i think this is what certainly what
council of white and to a lesser extent
my other equine friend from burnham uh
was alluding to as well you know we
really want to be careful because bridal
weights are quite big so
you know if the developers then got to
incorporate bridal ways into this scheme
they may well come back and say i'm
sorry you've dealt with the strategic
landscape and there is no
more room gentlemen i think i've made my
point yes and i think we would be i
think you know members were mindful to
approve this outline application i think
we should be mindful of that too and and
perhaps an amendment thank you
okay yes you wanted to answer that mr
johnson yeah the um
this is a conversation perhaps so well
probably i'm going to sort of sort of
make a point
um
the
yep this is a
this is within the context of an outline
plan a hybrid application
the
um
relief road
has got detailed approval
um the locations of the parcels of land
um has got
broad approval in terms of with their
locations where they will go
um
parameters are set in terms of you know
widths of road widths of footways etc
um
as cursor fluke pointed out the um and
from my own experience i'll add the size
of a bridal way adding this into a
scheme
in which the strategic routes through
the site has already been agreed
would substantially alter the character
of this application
um in terms of its outlying context
um
these are matters that would be
considered or
should have been considered if they
weren't considered uh clearly i wasn't
in the authority at the time on the more
strategic level in terms of these briber
ways um
i i personally would be concerned um and
we're really this is this is this is a
matter relating to this element of the
proposal this is
this is
i don't know
20 percent of the scheme this is phase
105.
um
[Music]
if we're talking about bridal ways how
we're talking about bridal's way
this application does relate does not
relate to the full length of the relief
road for example
this application does not relate to the
full length of the spine world
so where do you start where you begin in
terms of considering this because the
application in front of us relates to
um
phase one
only not the other joining phases
um that would be part of a more
strategic arrangement but that's not the
purpose of this application
thank you chairman all right i'm going
to move on now counselor swain you have
a
question oh yes thank you chairman
actually i have three um
areas that i wanted to ask some
questions observations um
continue with this uh the ring road um
issue
um
and i know from the um
that
was put up that the
road seems to be elevated
slightly from
the natural terrain
and i'm
concerned about
the noise outwards a lot has been said
about
noise
protection for the residential area
itself
but um is there any provisions for
serious noise
and visual
uh mitigation on the outside of this
like um this ring road or is that
treated as the highways responsibility
um secondly and i'm assuming that that
bond will be largely built up from
material excavated on-site
the other point is about access from the
residential areas to across the the ring
road um
i'm not sure where there's any provision
for that but it is rather essential that
people can relate to the countryside
beyond the development
that's the first area of german
okay mr johnson
so the ring road noise outwards and the
access road across the ring road service
uh thank you jimmy
just for clarification council is saying
when you say that the ringing road do
you mean the relief road or do you you
mean the relief road
oh i just wanted to declare
foreign road we're talking about
the
the relief right
right so specifically in terms of noise
out do you do you mean noise from the
ring road and how that would impact on
the development
i'm talking about noise outwards to the
open countryside and how far that will
actually
impact
on whether mitigation measures on the
outside of that road
um
to deal with noise and visual intrusion
um
well as i said
before and i stated in the report the um
the road was part of the detailed
elements of the original application so
the road is set in terms of where it is
in its relationship etc yeah
um as part of this landscaping scheme
and this this plan here i think is ideal
in that sense it does show
the amount of
hedgerows
to be aligned along
the northern
and the southern part
well the northern and southern in terms
of the western section
um of the relief road
uh very abuts
the countryside or the more open land
areas and then to the east of
maple road
on the northern side again there is that
continuation of the hedgerow line again
which was alluded to earlier so in terms
of noise attenuation
in terms of
this visual impact
there will be landscaping relief in that
sense
so we're simply reliant upon a hedgerow
on the outer
side of this road
um
that is a scheme that we have in front
of us i'm not sure what
other matters
is
what i was getting at is it a
responsibility of the developer to
produce something
more effective in terms of noise and
visual impact outwards to the investment
to the countryside
um well in terms of this application the
landscaping proposals is considered to
be
acceptable from in terms of the
recommendation put in front of you
okay what's your next question
um yes the second concerns sads
um
which obviously could be um
well used in future for
for
retaining flood waters
um
i would like to have some idea of what
is the percentage of
the green space that is actually going
to be taken up with these swales and
attenuation ponds and so on because it
seems to me they
from a practical point of view um
not only is there a
risk
the children
if you do have a lot of water and some
of these deeper swales
um but actually they're not really
contributing much
as green space
for the community so it's a question of
whether whether the amount needed to
satisfy the essex country council on
flood alleviation it actually
minimizes or reduces greatly the
effective green space that that
residents will be able to use
all right thank you chair um
the
the attenuation
um measures in this proposal
uh do survey dual purpose
um
in
drier times um they have been so
designed and
landscaped um particularly in terms of
access to them sort of shallow accesses
that they can be used
um
for
recreational purposes clearly in times
of heavy rainfall or
flood situations they will not be used
at those at those times
um
this is a single element of a five-phase
proposal for this redevelopment site i
can't say what percentage overall
that they represent
in terms of
the um
green space at the community can use for
recreational purposes so that i can't
comment on
um
this is just a discrete element
so there was another part to your
question that
i thought you mentioned that might have
escaped me um well i i was concerned
that if these are uh
these swales and and attenuation
areas do have a significant amount of
water do they not constitute a
risk
a safety risk for um residents young
very young residents well in
that safety risk would have been
considered in terms of the the
evaluation of them through the
sustainable urban drainage scheme
um it is not considered that the risk
that
you might have in mind is not the risk
that the experts have
um
assess
that would take place in terms of
um
risk to i don't know life and limb if
you want to put it that way
um
i think i think at this stage um
if i can feed a page 33 this is the
essex county council of suds
lead local flood authority and they
don't have any objections to that i
understand i understand what you're
saying but i don't think that's relevant
to this application okay i said that and
maybe there's more to be said when it
comes to detail yeah stage on this um
my third one concerns um
our archaeological um
um investigations it uh is um
said that there are some you know there
were we expect that there were
um archaeological
artifacts and interests in this area
and it
says in some section that more work is
needed to be done on that more
investigation and yet it doesn't it says
the development or
process progress with the development
won't have an impact
but if you're digging out all these
swells attenuation ponds and um putting
in roads and so on um
isn't that going to actually rather um
destroy areas which might have been
worth excavating for archaeological
purposes
i mean
i think as i mentioned on another
question previously um
this application is to consider the
landscaping elements it doesn't
it doesn't circumvent the need for the
archaeological explorations to take
place
the archaeological
exploration and to satisfy that
condition
is
sort of scheme-wide
so
if this application was approved today
it doesn't mean they could
sort of you know run along the next day
and excavate these areas and not have
carried out the archaeological
investigations it doesn't mean that at
all
okay thank you um councillor voice
thank you chairman um
this um
uh
seems to me uh like somebody sitting
down with a sheepskin
uh a sheep fleece rather
and carving it spinning it weaving it
sewing it together to make a garment
at each stage
there
could be a drop stitch
and i think members concerns here is
dealing with an application as large as
this
uh with reserve matters coming in on
individual
cases
but members are concerned that there
will be a mis-stitch somewhere that is
not quite knitted or sewn together the
whole the whole thing and something will
go and miss i think councillor uh fluker
um
uh referred to it as did uh councillor
white and
um hull um but on condition one
uh remembering again that this is
a reserved matter for
whatever it is but condition one
uh says um
articulated vehicle tracking and bus
tracking
uh mr johnson i think said this earlier
that transport wasn't an issue here but
there is
development shall be carried out in
accordance with the following approved
plans and documents
so therefore unless
art articulated a vehicle tracking means
something different
to what i think uh
it means
um uh councillor white's
uh issues were very relevant to this
application
thank you chairman um
we're just taking the tracking um
drawings which you saw earlier and as
related refer to in in in proposed
conditions
i mean if we look at 5.7.2 and the waste
comments
um they've confirmed that the vehicle
tracking for the refuse vehicles
into the
well different parcels appeared to be
sufficient to allow the 26 ton refuge
vehicles to drive in and out
of each parcel
as part of any residential reserve
matter submission consideration will be
given to individual houses and or
communal collection points so in terms
of
the strategic elements
the
use of vehicles of that size necessary
to service this type of development
in and out of the various areas not into
the discrete areas but in and out of
these broad areas
just as outlined on this element of the
application uh these are considered to
be satisfactory
and there are no objections
determined
this
this
in my view contradicts uh the issues
that councillor channel raised and um uh
councillor white
they were concerned and asked and
councillor channel asked for assurances
um that the outlying condition complies
with et cetera et cetera
but we do seem to have a dichotomy here
uh there
uh mr johnson's saying that
the the issue of yellow lines
it came down to wasn't a matter for this
um
for this application
but
one of the conditions relates to
large vehicle movements which
miss white referred
i'm not well i think as as i said before
now i think you if you don't mind me
saying chairman i think council catholic
heard um mentioned this point
yellow lines and the
physical development of a
highway in terms of its width is
capacity
junctions and radii etc yeah which is
what this relates to in terms of
tracking is not the same as
highway management
which we're talking about in terms of
yellow lines so
i don't see there being a dichotomy
they're clearly two different matters
um yellow lines and it depends on
whether uh rose within this development
would be adopted
by the local highway or not they could
be adopted they may not be adopted if
they're not adopted they're not subject
to those sorts of controls
so this application just relates to
these physical matters which we consider
under a planning application
and in the context of this reserve
matters for this parcel i don't see
there being a dichotomy at all no i
would say again the essex county council
highways have been
asked to comment they have commented and
they've no objections to make on this
um
proposal
which is for landscaping
council morris
thank you i'd just like to take this
opportunity to uh
voice what my residents
believe of this development which is
that it is awful
um
for obvious reasons schools doctors
transport various other things like
things we've heard a thousand times that
we don't address
um i'd just like to ask mr johnson um
i've only got this opportunity to really
do it
if this isn't anything to do with the
reserve matters that are here today if
you could let me know please
um i've got two questions i'd like to
know that um at the end of haybridge
approach
we have the roundabout and um the
roundabout basically should have been
opened and ran
straight um you know up from haybridge
approach but instead we decided to
uh run the little relief road off of
langford road
which doesn't make much sense to me and
looks like it'll cause more traffic this
is now being called the langford rectory
bypass i was wondering if i could get
some reasons as to
why we didn't open up the roundabout and
you know we've run
literally the relief road around the
houses
and the second one is in layman's terms
please mr johnson uh could we let
everyone know because i'm hoping that
we've got a few residents
from haybridge
watching on the youtube
right now could you tell us in layman's
terms what is going to happen
about the
risk of flooding what we actually going
to do to mitigate flooding please no
acronyms
no
planning terminology just in layman's
terms for the residents of oakbridge
thank you
thank you chairman thank you councillor
um
in terms of
the
the relief road strategy its location
all this details
um
that has already been agreed um
that's not part of this application but
i think has mentioned because the
landscaping flanks it
um is to just remind members that
where the road is
where the roundabout is where everything
is that is already fixed we can't go
back on that
um
[Music]
so that would answer that first question
uh inter in terms of the second question
um
i'm trying to put it in lay person's
terms we did discuss some of these
matters in terms of some of the some of
the questions there uh earlier
um this application is about the
landscaping it's not it's not about the
suds application it details where
the
relevant
um
attenuation the ponds yeah are going to
go um as part of the landscaping scheme
and how they can be incorporated to the
landscaping scheme so they're not just
ditches waiting to be filled with water
they can be used for
substantial well i won't say substantial
um
others with
local knowledge may know more than me
but with you know
a fair amount of the year they'll be
used for recreational purposes
and basically how they will contribute
to the
landscape and design ethos of the area
but they are not the landscaping scheme
and and i couldn't ask you a question in
any event because this is just one
discreet element of the overall proposal
it's not me kind of interference
somewhere okay we're all right now thank
you
yeah this is just one one element of it
um proposing the contribution of this
part this phase of the five phase
development of of of of of the garden
suburb
in terms of where its
flood
alleviation
system would go
it can't speak for the whole of the
development under this application in
fact it can't even speak fully for this
one it's just showing where it goes and
i think there are other
accompanying documents um as mentioned
before that would need to be read and
that will also be coming forward
okay sorry that's the best i can say yes
sir
but i also refer you to page 33 these
are comments from the essex county
council highways and and the suds
yeah i've read them okay what's your
supplementary please thank you mr
johnson i always find you very
informative and diligent so thank you
for that
so just to um
reiterate though the um roundabout
that uh
you know i'm going to refer to as the
langford rotary bypass
could you please let me know i know it's
already done and dusted but i would
still like to know because i did ask way
back and didn't get an answer from
anyone not yourself so i'd like to know
about the um haybridge approach
roundabout langford dructry bypass and
are you basically saying that currently
is all we're going to have is some ponds
to collect the uh possible flood water
well i mean they're referred to as as as
ponds but they they are
going to use a nomenclature
attenuation basins
um they will absorb and soak up and they
will hold water
um they will release them
naturally uh again to attenuate the flow
you know for the bees water cascading
down so to speak
that's their purposes and that's the
reason why they are located where they
are relevant to the
water table in that particular area
the
uh gradient of the land as i mentioned
earlier there's a four and a half meter
slope from north or south of the site
which again is relevant to all you know
the flooding
and also the fact that with the new
development you will have
hard surfacing
um
materials are yet to be uh fully agreed
but they will be permittable materials
but again it's all part of a package of
the measures again which will be
detailed
um and uh
with concurrent and subsequent
applications again this is one part of
the whole development as
as mentioned
you know there are also swells as
mentioned before running alongside the
the relief road they're also culverts
to direct the water uh from off the
roads uh into channels underneath the
roads again to to take it off so there's
a whole package of measures i understand
in lieu of
what was originally anticipated for the
site some years back
thank you okay so they're going to do
the bare minimum they can get away with
and just hope the heavens don't well i
think he's answered your question but
thank you for that um councillor stilts
you're next
thank you mr chairman um can i refer to
page 28
5.6.6 we talk about um a survey that was
done for badger sets and bats
and they actually found that there was
an inhabitated badger set and it says
here that construction cannot start
until a development license has been
legally obtained
is this going to affect that badger set
and has the developer obtain that
license yet
um well the license is not a planning
matter i i can't comment on
i mean that's that's an obligation as a
legal obligation on behalf of the
developer that they would have to take
care but they'd have to obtain before
any words can be carried out otherwise
they will be flouting the law
um
the
if this application was supported today
that does not mean they can go ahead and
do this without obtaining any license or
any other requirements that they need
before development can start
is this part of the development going to
affect that badger set uh because this
is talking about 2022
but is this
green
bit that we're talking about today this
phase one going to affect
uh i'll have to say kels i don't
specifically know where the badger set
is but it as it's been mentioned
in this application it will be within
this area
um i have to say i don't
personally know exactly where it is but
it's within this development hence it
being covered under the considerations
here so they'll need a license before
they can do that anyway okay cancer
cydle
thank you chairman
um i think we got a bit lost at times in
terms of what this application is about
it's it's not about some of the things
that have been discussed this evening it
is about the entrance it is about green
landscaping and and that's important
thing to consider
and it is going to come in phases as mr
johnson said so we need to consider
those phases as as they get developed
the interesting about this the green
infrastructure
part of this development is in the great
tottenham ward
and if you look at maple road at the
moment there's very little green
infrastructure along that road there's
very little hedges there's trees at the
bottom of it when you get to the
haybridge parish but the rest of that
road there isn't any landscaping there
isn't anything at the moment that stops
noise there isn't anything that then it
is enhancing the environment so in many
ways this is adding to
and benefiting
what we've got so the interesting thing
is about this is it's actually adding
more green infrastructure to this part
of the district
um in terms of
most roads in the district if you look
at them and they are country roads and
this will be a country road a b road
probably
they don't have lots of noise screening
they have hedge rows that's the natural
environment in in the mold industry
hedgerows that's what the developers
putting in so the developers doing their
best to ensure that what's being put
here
is right for this part of the district
the thing we have to remember with this
particular application is this
application came forward under the
previous administration we are now doing
our best
to ensure that this application is fit
for purpose
um and it's important that we recognize
that so we need to ensure that there is
that is right but we are considering at
the moment the landscaping element and
it's important to concentrate on that
thank you
thank you very much right okay i think
we've given that a fair um
a fair debate um if it's very short
council channel i'll come back to you
i'll come back to you council swain and
i know councillor edward says the ward
member he wanted to say something else
later
just an observation okay council channel
briefly please
thank you chairman
yeah thank you chairman i will be quick
um
due to a question that council stilts
asked and i just need to get
clarification here make sure i heard it
right and it was to do with the badger
set
and about licensing and councillor still
solves that question i think the
response from the officer was
that a licence was a legal matter not a
planning one
however we have a condition and bearing
mind conditions have to be reasonable
and enforceable
condition number three does relate to a
license being a requirement says no set
closure shall in any circumstances can
let the commence unless the local
planning authority has been provided
with either a license issued by natural
england
and b a statement in writing so i'm a
little bit confused because the officer
said a license was a legal matter not
planning and yet we were putting on an
application on this application should
it be approved
a condition
and bearing in mind reasonable and
enforceable can i then have assurances
therefore or have i misheard something
um my assurance is therefore this
condition is reasonable and enforceable
um or have i misinterpreted what the
officer responded chairman i do
apologize if i have upfront mr johnson
you will answer that
thank you i'm just
reading through that okay
my understanding of the condition is
that um
it's no no set enclosure
shall in any circumstances commence
unless the local planet authority has
been provided with et cetera et cetera
but the the setting closure is the
protective measures uh for the set
the uh in a way we can sort of see this
like a
the tree protection measures
that we would normally require through
conditions
um so that's that's my understanding of
this condition and the reason for it the
obtaining of the license itself is not a
planning matter
but any development that would be
facilitated as a result of the setting
closures
it in itself is a planning matter
so that
indicates the reason for this condition
um and our awareness obviously of
the fact that you know we are dealing
with protective species although we
ourselves can't say that a license needs
to be
obtained okay thank you council swain
just briefly okay so it's very quick
point of clarification is it um
uh intended that each phase that the
suds in each phase of the development
will be capable of dealing with the
um
flood mitigation for that phase
thank you chairman um
it's the flood mitigation for the phase
but
that's part of the overall flood
strategy i mean the overall flood
strategy is for the site as a whole
um
the fact that
a particular flood mitigation may be
able to deal with the flooding in this
discrete area it doesn't necessarily
mean that
that sort of piecemeal approach means
that as a whole it deals with the
flooding on the site
um the various elements of flooding on
these applications is related to the
overall strategy for the entire site
these are just the discrete elements of
that overall strategy
okay and counselor edward's your
observation and then i'm going to move
to uh
an observation and a clarification
please um
an observation is we were talking about
right or ways earlier
um there are two i think riding school
just north of the relief road just
gotta make that point
um and the other clarification uh you
talk about parcels and phases
the phases of five phases over the next
10 years that's correct isn't it
the parcels are the actual developments
of the buildings which will come
separately is that correct yes so phases
and then parcels to follow into each
phase as each phase is completed is that
phases and passes within but does a
phase will the
with the parcels follow each phase in
that area in that phase yes right okay
thank you
okay members so um
we are
recorded vote police
okay first of all uh i'm i'm looking for
a proposal members the proposed major
proposal please
well the officer's recommendation is
that we approve subject to conditions
council swain
right okay in that case uh we will go
for the vote on that to approve this
recommendation now you ask for a
recorded vote
is that seconded
councillor legend seconds that so that's
what we will do then
are you able to call the role
so this is to approve this
recommendation as the officer's
recommendation yeah
okay thank you chairman members i will
call your names in alphabetical order
can you please stay clearly for against
or abstain using your microphones uh
starting with
cancer passenger we don't seem to have
cast passenger here but we didn't
receive apologies okay thank you um
councillor miss spiel
against
thank you counselor
sorry cancer biel council brian bill
thank you cancer boys
council mrs janna for
councillor dueck
for
councillor edwards
or
cancer fleming
paul
hubner
castle hall
against
caster keys
four
that's a lagoon
against casamays
thank you councillor
councillor sorry morris
against
that's the shauna c
against
thank you
counselor
siddle oh
that's the stamp
ball
anthony stephens
or
council stilts
against
councillor swain
paul
thompson
ball
thank you cancer white
against i had an alternative proposal
which obviously is lost now
thank you
thank you chairman members that's 14 4 7
against no abstentions
thank you that is approved then in that
case thank you
we move on to agenda item six this is
found on pages 41-52
this is mcdonald's at fullbridge
21
00270 slash adv
mr johnson i think you have the pleasure
of this one as well
okay so we'll just uh
listen
so
so i think we just need to note that uh
several members have left the meeting at
this stage
uh there is still sufficient here uh to
be caught
so i will carry on
fairman can we just um minute who's left
the meeting please
we have councillor fluka has left
councillor
um
council duik
and councillor boyce i think those
yes i've already made a note of that
chairman thank you very much
we need to know who's still here then
chairman
okay
okay so we're going to move on now to
agenda item number six
this is mcdonald's at full bridge
found members on pages 41 to 52 of the
report
so mr johnson
thank you chairman
um
this application proposes um
advertisement consent for the
installation of four number fascia signs
to the
mcdonald's in full bridge
so again we just have the site here
a location plan
and here we have an aerial photograph
the existing
site
and here we have the
existing elevations
um what i'll be doing is just flipping
between the two because
um
[Music]
the changes may appear quite subtle um
and to just
get an appreciation you may just need to
go backwards and forwards between the
existing and and the proposed
so we can see we've got these
uh again standard signage i think it was
mentioned earlier that um
um a number of you are fully aware of
the site here
[Music]
this application seeks to change the
nature of the signage in line with
their current
brandon
um for this site
so again just to
i mean we've got the various elevations
here
and again just to show you the
differences
um that triangular section there
the change here
side elevation there
again we can just see the change in
color of the roof roofing materials
again
on the other side
you can see again oops
the change in the
emblems there
roofing materials
and
again
we can see the changes here so these are
this is a substance of the application
that that weight that we're looking at
um
just see the photograph of the
site here
i mean as noted from the report this was
a
um it was requested by central uh
planning that this be considered by
members given the nature of
the voting at that committee
um officer's recommendation is that um
these are relatively minor changes
for the reasons stated change of
branding
and as such the advertisement
applications are recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you mr johnson um
i will open this up to the floor
counselor morris
i'd like to propose that we uh go
against the officer's recommendations
and refuse this
um mcdonald's are the largest toy
distributor in the world and i don't
think that morgan district council
should have anything to do with
promoting such an unhealthy food choice
for our young people um i'd like is
anyone prepared to second that
it would appear not so the
uh proposal is that uh the rec the
officer's recommendation is that we
grant advertisement consent do
do i have a seconder
casa siddill thank you uh
can we agree that by a cent recorded
vote please is that seconded
it is not seconded can we agree on that
by ascent
you're
um
it's noted that is noted
okay um any other items of business that
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent
uh there are none
um
other than to politely request
councillor morris if you're going to
have a meal would you kindly not do it
in the chamber i'll do what i want thank
you very much mark
you're an idiot in the milk wendy told
me
i think councillor morris it is clear
that you are on a personal crusade
i think that's your opinion and i don't
value your opinion very much it does not
the findings of an independent
investigator no it wasn't very
independent
wasn't very
i'm not completely without friends wendy
wendy thinks you're an idiot and so do i
an alarming code alarming i really
couldn't care what you think mark
process you are a milk and you are an
idiot
you watched homophobic bullying go on
and you did nothing
you